Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Cecilia Bernabeni
[Azione chiama, genera,
crea, ispira azione]
[Il conto alla rovescia
non lascia scampo]
[Possiamo fermare
il cambiamento climatico]
Ho da poco compiuto 50 anni,
e non sono mai stato
una persona che fa bilanci,
o che guarda indietro
e che fa i bilanci della vita.
Però in questo periodo,
forse anche per l'età,
sto pensando a quanto sia importante
l'epoca in cui una persona vive,
quanto avvengono succedono
delle cose epocali,
dei periodi storici che forse
vengono ricordati, e verranno ricordati,
perché sono particolari
e innescano dei meccanismi
che sono ricordati poi per sempre
come dei momenti importanti.
Pensate, per esempio, alle donne
che hanno votato per la prima volta
quando è stato concesso
il diritto di voto alle donne.
Pensate far parte di quel momento storico.
O in Sudafrica,
quando Mandela finalmente ha vinto
la rivoluzione sociale e culturale,
e ha invertito in maniera
non bellicosa, ma pacifica,
il corso delle cose.
Pensate a chi ha vissuto quei momenti.
Pensate a chi ha vissuto
nella Rivoluzione Industriale,
e improvvisamente si è passati
da un modo di produzione agricola
a uno improvvisamente diverso,
e si è fatto parte di quella storia.
Purtroppo, c'è anche
chi ha vissuto le guerre.
Mia nonna ne ha vissute due, di guerre.
È importante, l'epoca in cui si vive.
Ecco: io sento che questa è un'epoca
in cui sta avvenendo una rivoluzione
forse più silenziosa ma molto forte,
che è quella dello sviluppo sostenibile,
della green economy.
E penso anche di essere
particolarmente fortunato.
E secondo me lo siete anche voi,
ma vi dico dopo perché.
Ora, perché questa rivoluzione
dello sviluppo sostenibile accade?
È vero che è una rivoluzione,
o è una nostra,
una mia idea, un mio sogno?
Per capirlo, vediamo insieme
che cos'è una rivoluzione.
Quand'è che possiamo dire
che siamo nel mezzo di una rivoluzione?
Secondo me,
un modo per definire una rivoluzione
è quello per cui,
in un determinato momento,
alcune cose che sembravano impossibili
sembrano improvvisamente normali.
Guardate, ad esempio, queste immagini.
Guardate, ad esempio,
questa classe di liceo del 1966.
Guardate come sono vestiti,
la lunghezza dei capelli,
il sorriso, lo sguardo,
la lunghezza delle gonne,
dei vestiti delle ragazze.
E guardate questa classe
del 1969, tre anni dopo.
È cambiato tutto.
La lunghezza dei capelli;
guardate come ridono,
guardate come si vestono le ragazze,
guardate come si pongono
rispetto alla vita.
E se non siamo ancora convinti,
guardate una band musicale del '66
e una band musicale del '69:
poi erano tutte così,
tre anni dopo, le band musicali.
In soli tre anni è cambiato tutto.
Perché?
Perché senza dubbio, il 1968
è stata una vera rivoluzione.
Ora vediamo se questa
dell'economia è vera.
Ho preso le copertine dell'Economist,
la rivista più importante
del mondo dell'economia
e della finanza mondiale,
con focus europeo ma mondiale,
e guardate quali erano
le copertine degli anni '90.
Rischio finanziario; privatizzazione;
valore delle azioni e degli azionisti.
Guardate nel 2000 la stessa rivista,
con lo stesso target
e la stessa proprietà,
che cosa pubblica in copertina:
"I polmoni del mondo";
"Le foreste, e come salvarle";
"La felicità, e come misurarla";
"Fermiamo i cambiamenti climatici".
L'Economist! Non la rivista
di Greenpeace o del WWF.
Quindi, questa rivoluzione sta accadendo
perché improvvisamente,
nessuno l'avrebbe pensato,
l'economia e le imprese -
e adesso anche la finanza -
stanno dalla parte dei rivoluzionari,
e non dalla parte della resistenza.
Questo è molto importante,
e questo ci dice che siamo
in un momento di rivoluzione particolare,
che è quella della green economy
e dello sviluppo sostenibile.
Ma qual è questa rivoluzione?
Questa rivoluzione nasce
dal fatto che improvvisamente,
l'economia ha avuto bisogno
di avere sempre un'altra parola vicino.
Vi ricordate?
Si comincia a parlare da vent'anni
di "new economy", "soft economy",
"blue economy", "green economy";
e l'economy ha sempre avuto
bisogno di un aggettivo
perché vuol dire che l'economy,
da sola, non funzionava più.
Perché il centro della rivoluzione
è quello per cui l'economia
ha scoperto che c'è bisogno
di un nuovo rapporto con il pianeta,
di un nuovo rapporto
con l'ambiente in cui viviamo.
E allora, la ricerca continua
di aggettivi da aggiungere
è semplicemente perché non funziona più:
è come se un'automobile
dovessimo chiamarla
"pseudo-automobile",
o "automobile del futuro" -
ma mai automobile normale.
Perché non c'è più, l'automobile normale.
Ecco, siamo in questo momento particolare;
E adesso vi dico perché sono fortunato.
Perché quando io mi sono laureato
in Diritto dell'Ambiente, nel '93,
facevo giurisprudenza e ho scelto
una tesi in Diritto dell'Ambiente,
mi davano tutti come un mezzo pazzo
perché nessuno pensava che quella
fosse una materia interessante.
Ma io sentivo una cosa:
io sentivo che siccome avevo
una passione fortissima
per l'ambiente e per i boschi,
stavo bene quando stavo
vicino alla natura,
volevo unire questa passione
con gli studi di Giurisprudenza.
E quindi ho tentato l'unica cosa
che metteva insieme
queste due possibilità:
Raimondo che va nei boschi,
e Raimondo che si laurea
in Giurisprudenza alla Luiss di Roma.
Lanciato verso un futuro - probabilmente,
sperabilmente, di successo -
laureandomi in diritto dell'ambiente.
Ecco: sono stato fortunato,
perché non sapevo che era cominciata
quella rivoluzione.
Mi trovavo ancora in quello
un modello di economia
estrattiva, emissiva, lineare,
che è questo che vedete.
C'era ancora l'economia prevalente -
che ahimè, è ancora prevalente nel mondo,
perché la rivoluzione
è appena cominciata -
in cui noi prendiamo le risorse naturali,
costruiamo e facciamo i prodotti,
li usiamo, ce ne disfiamo
non sapendo neanche dove vanno
e non ce ne curiamo,
e quindi inquiniamo.
Modello estrattivo, emissivo, lineare:
la "brown economy".
Io stavo proprio in quel mezzo,
ma stavo guardando avanti.
E non sapevo che stava nascendo
la "green economy":
un'economia in cui il riciclo,
le fonti rinnovabili,
l'agricoltura biologica,
le città rigenerate,
stavano mettendosi in moto;
e quindi era un momento epocale
di passaggio alla green economy.
E quindi sono stato fortunato
perché poi ho trovato lavoro,
e anzi ho unito questi due aspetti
e sono riuscito a portarli avanti,
diciamo, con discreto successo.
Ma soprattutto
con soddisfazione interiore,
che è la cosa più importante.
Ma la cosa che voglio dirvi, oggi,
è che questa rivoluzione importante
è in una terza fase.
Una fase che ancora non conosciamo,
ma che sentirete nominare
moltissimo, nei prossimi anni.
Si sta passando dalla "green economy",
quindi l'economia
dello sviluppo sostenibile -
che stiamo tentando di attuare:
con difficoltà, ma stiamo
in questo passaggio -
all'economia rigenerativa:
ricordatevelo, rigenerativa.
Lo sentirete spesso, questo termine.
Perché è così importante
l'economia rigenerativa?
Qual è un esempio che possiamo fare
di economia rigenerativa?
Ecco, pensiamo un attimo a questo signore
che si chiama Kenneth Bodin,
che nel 1966 -
cioè prima di tutto questo,
e prima che io nascessi -
tirò fuori, come spesso accade,
una teoria che allora
non fu pienamente compresa,
cioè quella per cui la nostra terra,
il nostro pianeta, è come un'astronave.
Dobbiamo considerarla come un'astronave
che si muove nello spazio da sola,
e che quindi ha delle risorse necessarie
che le sono state date in partenza
per poter sopravvivere e muoversi.
Ma ha tutto un meccanismo interno
per riciclare, riutilizzare,
rigenerare queste risorse.
Altrimenti finisce di muoversi:
esplode o implode,
e comunque finisce il suo viaggio.
Ecco: la Terra è come quell'astronave.
Per l'economia rigenerativa -
e guardate questo tentativo
di spiegazione:
l'economia rigenerativa è quell'economia
che invece di pensare
a non danneggiare il pianeta,
come la green economy,
tenta di andare oltre.
Non solo non lo danneggiamo -
e già questo sarebbe tantissimo -
ma addirittura rigeneriamo
alcuni fattori ambientali
che sono stati danneggiati
dalla "brown economy" di prima,
di quando Raimondo non sapeva neanche
perché sentiva questa ambizione.
Questi aspetti che andiamo a rigenerare
sono i fiumi, i mari, i suoli,
la qualità della terra.
Si sono contaminati,
[ma] possono essere rigenerati.
Perché questi stock di capitale naturale,
che noi utilizziamo per produrre,
che ci servono,
sono dati gratis.
Se siamo credenti, ce li dà Dio;
se siamo atei, ci vengono dati comunque
dal pianeta, dalla natura;
ma comunque ci vengono dati gratis.
Noi li utilizziamo:
ma li stiamo contaminando,
quindi stiamo consumando
tutta quell'energia e tutto quel capitale
che rende possibile a questa astronave
di continuare a viaggiare.
L'economia rigenerativa
tenta di ricostituirli, rigenerarli,
quindi purificarli,
facendo delle azioni economiche.
Pensate all'agricoltura biologica.
Pensate a quelle forme di agricoltura
che invece di assorbire
la qualità del terreno,
e poi distruggerlo -
perché dopo 20 anni, ad esempio,
un'agricoltura intensiva
distrugge un terreno
e bisogna cambiare posto -
invece la rigenera continuamente,
attraverso la biodiversità
che viene nutrita.
Pensate a un'attività
di bonifica dei siti,
di bonifica dei mari,
di bonifica dei fiumi:
sono attività che producono PIL,
posti di lavoro, occupazione.
E scommettono sul fatto
che il nostro futuro verrà garantito.
È questa, la rivoluzione silenziosa.
Tantissime imprese
si stanno muovendo in questo senso,
ce ne sono tante;
e lo sforzo che dobbiamo fare
è veramente tanto.
Guardate la curva
delle emissioni di gas serra,
quanto sta salendo:
sta ancora salendo.
E guardate quanto deve scendere
nei prossimi 10 - 15 anni:
un cambio completo,
un'inversione di rotta.
Ma ce la possiamo fare,
perché c'è questa rivoluzione in corso
che dobbiamo interpretare
e far diventare realtà.
Allora il mio messaggio di oggi -
che viene dalla mia esperienza
ed è quello che io sto provando a fare:
ma la cosa bella è che siamo
in tanti e tante imprese -
è che nella nostra vita,
non solo familiare e personale
ma nel nostro lavoro,
qualsiasi lavoro facciamo,
proviamo a inserire
i principi della "green economy",
e soprattutto della
"economia rigenerativa".
In qualsiasi lavoro facciamo -
e l'ho visto facendo l'avvocato,
volendo fare l'avvocato -
c'è sempre la possibilità
di fare qualcosa per il nostro pianeta.
Pensiamoci, e mettiamola in pratica.
E vorrei chiudere raccontandovi
questa brevissima storia
che mi ha raccontato
l'ambasciatore della Cina,
e io spero che la Cina poi
la realizzi veramente, questa storia.
Mi diceva se io conoscevo
la storia delle montagne.
Io ne conosco tante,
ma questa delle montagne
in particolare no.
E lui mi disse:
"Prima, per costruire la Montagna d'Oro
noi distruggevano la Montagna Verde.
Poi abbiamo capito,
dopo aver fatto tanti danni,
che mentre costruivamo la Montagna d'Oro
dovevamo conservare e preservare
la Montagna Verde:
era importante mantenerla così com'era.
Oggi siamo in una terza fase.
Oggi abbiamo capito che la Montagna Verde
è la Montagna d'Oro".
In bocca al lupo a tutti noi.